يلوح هذا الرجل بعلامه التحدي السربيا
وكان الرسوم على الجدار لا تكفي للافصاح
عن هويه المكان هذا هو الجزء الشمالي من
ميتروفيتس تعده كوسوفو جزءا من اراضيها
لكن سكانه السرذ يرفضون الانقياد لحكمتها
لم يتجاوز الاهالي هنا العداوات العرقيه
ولم ينسوا بعد حروبا مضت عليها عقود وقرون
اين حقوق الصلب الذين يعيشون
رزنامه نحن في القرن الحادي والعشرين
وتريدون منا التحويل على امريكا وبريطانيا
والمانيا هل نسيتهم كم بقيه الهند تحت
العبوديه
لا يقبلوا كثيرون هنا بتغيير لوحات
سياراتهم الصربيه الى اخرى كوسفيه يكتفي
اخرون بتغطيه العالم الصربي تجنبا
للمشكلات هذا الشرطي من الاغلبيه الالباني
استقال نحو 500 من زملائه الذين ينتمون
الى الاقليه الصربيه كذلك فعل نواب ووزراء
رفض الصلب المشاركه في انتخابات المحليه
ويطالبون باتحاد لبلدياتهم بصلاحيات
استثنائيه
رياضه
اثر في المجتمعات المحليه
فككت قوات حفظ السلام الدوليه متاريس
وضعها ناشطون سر لعشرين يوما في 14 بلده
الشهر الماضي هدات الاوضاع اخيرا لكنه
هدوء يخشى كثيرون ان يكون مؤقتا على الرغم
من هدوء الاوضاع المدنيه في شمال كسوفو
الا ان الانقسام المجتمع باطن فهذا الجسر
الذي يقسم مصر الى جزئين البانيا وصربي
مغلق منذ سنوات وينتظر حلا سياسيا كي يعاد
فتحه ويننهي الحاجه الى مثل هذه القوات
الدوليه لحفظ السلام محمد المدهون الجزيره
من بلده مترو فيتسامه شماليه